تبكي الامهات في ايران على عتبات مدارس
بناتهن العالقات في صفوف الدراسه
ويصرخن لاخراجهن قبل اختناقهن بهواء مسموم
بمواد ما تزال مجهوله لكنها على حد وصف
الفتيات كريهه وتشبه رائحه فاكهه متعفنه
ومن خرجت منهن فتبدو عليهن حاله اعياء غير
مفسره والحافلات تشارك سيارات الاسعاف في
نقلهن الى المستشفيات 50 مدرسه على الاقل
تواجه ازمه تسمم باعتراف وزير الداخليه
احمد وحيدي موضحا ان صحه الطالبات تمثل
الاولويه القصوى لجميع المسؤولين ليؤكد ان
المحققين استعادوا عينات مشبوهه مكتفيا
بهاتين الكلمتين دون اي تفاصيل اخرى ليضيف
اليهما دعوه الى الهدوء متهما للعدو
بالارهاب الاعلامي هجمه كيماويه هكذا
تسميها عوائل البنات التي يلفظ على صدورهم
يتمددن على اسره المستشفيات وكل منهن
تعاني توعكا ما بين غثيان ووهن ودوار
وسعال وضيق في التنفس
420 ناشطا سياسيا ومدنيا وصفوا في بيان
مشترك عمليه التصميم بالعمل الاجرامي ونقل
اعلام المعارضه الايراني عن المتخصص الطبي
محمد رضا هاشميان ان الاشخاص العاديين لا
يمكنهم الوصول الى الغازات التي تم
استخدامها لتصميم الطلاب
اما شيرين عبادي احدى الشخصيات البارزه
المعارضه للنظام فقالت انه اذا كان هناك
اي شك حول دور النظام في مسلسل تسميم
الطالبات فقد زال هذا الشك اليوم